you
[Music]
so Jack what you up to
I've been enjoying all that gratz has to
offer well we really should be getting
over to the factory you can do to come
yes Jessica
[Music]
the word grats comes from the Slavic
word meaning small Castle says here the
grants has six universities one of the
best-preserved city centres in central
europe it's all very interesting jack
but we've must really get over to that
pace launched in rats has over a
thousand different architectural styles
to see 34 museums two galleries
festivals exhibitions are lively
covering comedy scene and over seven
hectares of contemporary sculpture and
you're taking me to see a factory yep
sure AM it's better beware
it'll be worth it trust me
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome I am Chuck white for
and you join me live here in Graz
Austria for the launch of Jaguars first
ever electric vehicle the new Jaguar
ipace but why am I in grass it's a
question I have been asking myself again
and again gratz widely regarded as one
of Europe's greatest cities it had why
laughing that serious it has so much to
offer
like the gratz burg a government
building which boasts two spiral
staircases which is the most spiral
staircases in any building in all of
Graz and you would be insane on your
trip not to go and visit the Shahs burg
wall voted one of the most beautiful
walls in all of Europe
if you like walls you came to the right
place but this is not a sure about gratz
no we're here because this is the
epicenter in the field of hydroelectric
power in the EU
you didn't think rats could get better
it just did I also bet you didn't know
that
Austria ranks amongst the most
specialized countries in Europe in the
field of mechanical engineering and
although the cars are designed and
engineered in the UK Jaguar produced
cars all over the world with this being
the actual state of the art production
facility where the e pace and now the
ipace are produced I mean literally
being produced right now I don't know
whether that is that gonna go on for the
whole show because I'm finding it quite
distracting could we stop it maybe maybe
kill it oh my god that's actually worked
I do okay we're not making any more epi
paces at the moment okay it's here that
up to a hundred and fifty robots like
that one behind me build the AI pace not
only though are we gonna be celebrating
the new Jaguar IPS launch but we will be
discovering how Jaguar are game changing
however if there are games to be played
there is only one man I want to my team
would you please welcome award-winning
motoring journalist and broadcaster
Johnny Smith
[Music]
hello jack
hello everybody it's a real pleasure to
be here to be part of this special
moment in Jaguar history 2018 is the
50th anniversary of the XJ model it's
also the 70th birthday of the eggs came
120 but today it's all about the
all-electric ipace and Jack you and I
want a bit of a voyage of discovery only
our voyage my voyage actually will
involve moving off this stage and over
there into the factory to see firsthand
what jag you would do how they work
their magic you sit here in your comfy
ipace chair and I'll just crack on Oh
off you go yeah I miss me one thing as
well Johnny when you're talking to the
factory workers try not to act manly
okay you let yourself down last time
Johnny we'll see you in a bit thank you
Cheers see you later Johnny
coming up on the show we're going to be
visiting Mexico ahead of this weekend's
Formula e race and I will be chatting to
two people called Ian one is the vehicle
line director for Jaguar the other is a
man who over the past 24 hours I have
bonded with in a serious and at times
passionate way Jaguar want me to call
him the director of design but the only
title I know him by now is the title a
friend
it's my new BAE my brother from another
mother the absolute dream boat that is
ian callum director of design absolute
legend absolute legend I also at this
point one to offer a special welcome to
those tuning in live around the world
including those in düsseldorf guten tag
and Oslo hello you can get involved
along with everyone else watching right
now around the world send in your
comments and questions please keep them
on topic know that I'll Sam I announce
that to the public you have no idea the
kind of suggestions I received use
hashtag Jaguar electrifies or hashtag
ipace and you lucky people will be the
first audience to see a brand new
documentary later on tonight
here is a little taster to whet your
appetite
[Music]
okay what
where's there's no seatbelt I can I'm
gonna have to risk it without looks
incredible right now I would like to
welcome our wonderful studio audience
yes here they are if if they weren't
excited enough already someone in this
room could be walking away tonight with
a brand-new ipace no you'll have to pay
for it that I made it sound like there
was a competition we're giving one away
not you you will have to pay for it but
you do find yourselves in a very
privileged position you're going to be
given an exclusive insight into the new
Jaguar ipace firstly to show you how
fast an eye base charges we are going to
turn on that car right now and the
charge will be shown right there on the
screen
40 minutes no problem I've heard you can
get up to a hundred kilometres by
plugging in for just 15 minutes that's
like chatting on your mobile phone for a
whole week on one 15 minute charge now
still to come we'll be heading over to
Mexico for an incredible challenge but
before we do today's event is already
causing quite the stir on social media
and here to keep a close eye on the buzz
is a lady who's shot to fame with her
unboxing films she knows her tech and
she knows how to take them out of boxes
not only that but her name is very on
brand it's the lovely iJustine thanks
jack and if you develop them to our
studio audience over 45,000 people
pressed the I want one button one on
Jaguar comm and we have so many people
here who are some lucky viewers or they
get to join us here for all of the spine
and the amazing reveal that we're gonna
have today plus we have fans tuning in
live all over the world and more
importantly they're getting involved by
using the hashtag Jaguar electrifies and
hashtag ipace so keep those messages
coming in we have a few here here from
Twitter we have max Coomer who says I am
so excited that Jaguar is now making
electric cars what a future forward
brand and we couldn't agree with you
more James says this is the most
beautiful Jaguar I have ever seen so you
guys keep those questions and your
comments coming in and we'll be reading
those all throughout the night now over
in the factory is Johnny Smith and my
question is Johnny where are you I'm
here Justine I'm here in the middle of
the plant where the very latest robot
technology
is right behind me as these eight
creatures construct the aluminium frame
of the eye pace and the whole procedure
is completely autonomous there's a bunch
of robots here all moving in absolute
unison it reminds me of that time I went
to the N Sync concert yeah anyway what
they're doing is they're using a
combination of rivets and aerospace glue
to construct the body show anyway just
yesterday the oil paste was put through
its paces its high paces where it took
on a challenge in Mexico with a little
help from the Panasonic Jaguar formula e
team and our presenter Natalie Pinker is
over there to join in with a
four-wheeled electric phone hello
Natalie very special reveal of the
brand-new Jaguar
ipace two cars two drivers and the
challenge naught to 60 miles per hour
and back to a standstill as fast as
possible join us a little later to find
out who wins
mmm I don't want to spoil things but I'm
pretty sure the better-looking proper
car wins the British one still to come
we have got the results of that race and
the car unveiling and even more
excitingly you in the studio and at home
will get to see the live sparkling
chemistry between me and my new best
friend
Ian Callum director of design please
remember to keep your questions and
comments coming in hashtag jaguar
electrifies and hashtag ipace as we get
ever closer to the reveal of the ipace
here in lovely grats anyway everyone is
always talking about smart technology if
like me you still think a CD Auto
changer is impressive then the ipace
will blow your tiny minds the new ipace
is so easy to get your head round one
could even call it child's play and here
is a short film that proves it
hi I'm here to pick up my new ipace okay
very funny are your parents here
[Music]
the whole car is a 4G Wi-Fi hotspot
where's the button to delete internet
history you know just in case um buying
a gift for someone I don't want them to
see what it is inside the cabin are six
USB ports guys already way ahead of you
I piece recognizes your key fob as your
approach and automatically adjusts to
your preferences like same jump seat
position and your favorite radio station
coming up next don't Celine Dion fm
obviously that's broken Youngblood
systems Bolton AI that's what I'm
talking about
spy stuff where is the ejector seat
button there is no eject to see hubcap
lasers it's a learning computer that
calculates your exact range based on
weather traffic and your driving style
you two are cramping my style
I'm out of here zero to 60 miles per
hour in 4.5 seconds 696 Newton meters of
torque talk I'm all about the talk you
don't even know what torque is do you
talk is my middle name
actually it says here it's Benedict any
questions
one question which one of you is gonna
teach me to drive you don't know how to
drive no I do
[Music]
well it can't be that hard
so it seems there are three golden rules
in this industry never work with
children animals or genic Whitehall's
anyway I'm in production heaven in the
middle of the factory where a
combination of humans and robots just
here fit the axle to the chassis now
even if you have no idea what an axle is
and you didn't know that it fits into a
street corner doesn't matter just look
at that precision this is a beautiful
sight and this happens here in gratz
every single day and this process of the
the engine or the electric motors being
joined to the body show is called the
marriage and in the case of the ipace
it's got two electric motors one on the
back axle and one on the front axle
because it's four-wheel drive now I'm
going to continue watching this for a
couple of minutes because I'm totally
transfixed by it and then I'm going to
come and join you Jack for the big
reveal
No either I've accidentally turned on
the heated seat or I've soiled myself
oh sorry so and I paste takes about
eight hours to build once it's in the
trim part of the factory but it only
takes a fraction of that time to charge
let's see where we are with our charging
studio car 38% not bad at all
and now the moment I've been waiting for
over in Mexico where the I pace is about
to take part in a fantastic head-to-head
challenge a quarter or mile a deserted
section of a formula e track two fully
charged batteries who will win I am on
the edge of my extremely comfortable and
well-designed iPay seat
[Music]
welcome to Mexico on Saturday this track
will host the latest round of the ABV
Formula e championship but we're here to
celebrate the launch of the brand-new
Jaguar
ipace with a very special challenge
showing the innovating from race to Road
has placed Jaguar at the forefront of
the TV revolution and here it is the I
paced all-electric all-wheel drive and
nought to 60 in just four point five
seconds so what of its Challenger we've
brought along a car from an established
player in the EU markets but does it
have what it takes to beat the Jaguar
ipace in our head-to-head challenge
driving the eye pace is panasonic Jaguar
racing Kiwi formulary star Mitch Evans
in the Tesla is Brazilian Indy 500
winner and former IndyCar champ Tony
Kanaan the challenge is very simple from
a standing start the drivers have to
reach 60 miles per hour as fast as
possible and then break to a standstill
the one carrying the shortest distance
wins
capiche I got it who's gonna win the eye
pace is later Darrell I've got this come
on then enough of the talking get in the
cars
so the pressure is on
can the ipace become the envy tipping's
this thing is a beast you've got zero
chance bring it on
[Music]
this is quite a walk may I smashed it
I need a faster car can you give me the
P 100 d well for the price of a P 100
day I could almost buy 2 of these
sure sure me I still get another car to
try ok that is the bigger brother to the
first Model X it's the 100 d it's more
powerful than the 75 d but will it be
quick enough to beat the AI pace let's
find out
[Music]
yes
so two of two Jagua have won it by
similar distance again
you're pretty smug and rightly so how
did it feel
yeah it was great the responses in sin
and also pulled up really well surprise
yes eight I had him but two out of two
oh I give up
proof then that Jaguar are really set to
shake out the Eevee revolution I think
we need to pop into Mexico City and
sample a few sights and delights I agree
dinner and he's buying it done come on
[Music]
yeah how is that for a challenge the
ipace one of course but what do you
expect from a car they can go from
nought to 60 in 4.5 seconds with a 90
kilowatt hour battery did I why why have
I started talking about Jeremy Clarkson
I don't know what have I seen electric
vehicle with a sports car performance
making it one of the greatest cars in
the world the new Jaguar ipace
sophisticated and great looking a bit
like its designer Ian Callum director of
design
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the reason we are
all here today in gratz police show your
appreciation for the stunning new Jaguar
I pace
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen I give you the
brand-new check your eye pace and it's
designer Ian Callum director of design
Wow Wow
can I just say so damn stylish and the
car is great as well I mean you must be
so proud it looks very crazy we're all
very proud of it yes I would drive that
car Jack you can't drive I would get
driven in that car it's beautiful
congratulations and I know how eager
many of you today are to get behind the
wheel of this car well now you can as of
this moment it is available to own now
still to come I'll be chatting to my new
best friend the yin to my yang the
secret to my roy ian callum director of
design and i'll also be meeting a second
Ian Ian Hoban don't worry you're my
favorite keep your questions coming in
hashtag Jaguar electrifies and hashtag
ipace now a chance to discover how the
Jaguar team produced not just another
electric car but a true Jaguar car that
sounded you like the sound of that
though I should do the voiceovers for
Jaguar definitely you're gonna this is
my favorite line in the whole script get
ready for this
brace yourself you're gonna love it the
car that electricity has been waiting
for
yeah that's good come on drag bigwigs
you love that let's find out a little
more I'm really passionate about
sustainability my business is based
around building low-energy houses and
encouraging people to live learners your
lifestyles so is this a family car as
well yeah absolutely
I mean really really a very good get
your packaging dimensions director and
so if the battery mounted on dampers or
something the battery is actually a
structural part of the car try again so
the batteries solidly mounted to the
frame we didn't think that's just a
massive advantage again it's harnessing
the benefits of having a battery of it
being an Eevee to make it a better car
yeah such fun and it's really incredible
it felt so sure-footed and it felt like
a proper off-roader you could actually
take it pretty much anywhere in the
space inside as well really impressive
felt very comfortable I'm 6 foot 4 from
Headroom and so that's all really good
with a TV with a good range and go
off-road can go very fast can do
everything I guess
[Music]
I'm joined by a Callen to take a closer
look around the new jag your IPAs hey
how are you yes good good so this is
your newest baby it is and the team yeah
and it's fair to say that it is
unconventional for a Jag
it is very unconventional anyway I mean
it's yeah quite different isn't it yeah
well for starters things in jankier
terms long bonnet where's that gone yeah
long bonnets we had long bonnets because
we're big engines ok the v8 so six
cylinders there is no engine the front
of this except a small electric motor
sitting between the wheels so we can
have a short bonnet and the great thing
about that of course is it gives all the
rest of the room over to the occupants
right advantage it's quite Aero
efficient was it designed by the wind
tunnel or was it designed by you a lot
of physics in this car I have to tell
you the airflow comes through this vent
here the front off the front flows over
the roof perfectly formed roof to hold
onto there
then through to the back but it holds on
to the car all the way through all but
physics this is quite an abrupt backside
can I say it is especially for a Jaguar
but you know believe it or not Square
back ends in the car are more efficient
for aerodynamics than rounded back ends
yep
worth bearing in mind yeah so we've cut
off the back and we've followed physics
30 on this car for the right reasons
yep right let's go into the place where
you live when you drive a car because
this is the thing I've got for you
viewers I'm a special I've got any in
Callum cam look come on cam it's a bit
creepy but don't worry it's so that I
can show people what we're going to talk
about take me through this because
obviously this is the place where you
live in a car so the cockpits all
important it is you know it's got more
space than it had before of a car of its
size but the great thing been working on
is the amount of usable space and the
practicality for instance the centre
console has got a an opening here under
the armrest and it's 10 litres of space
10/10 almost large enough to take a
handbag troika be useful goodness Johnny
that H big yeah that is big that's
fantastic yeah so you've got the
occupant space presumably to design
electric car is it a bit liberating
compared to what you're used to yes it's
usually liberating you know from the
wheel the wheel centers upwards it's
it's a free free range of for
so we can do what we want above it and
it meant it means we can do the shape
draw the shape that we want above the
wheels yeah it's radical its Israeli is
it fair to say that this is as radical
as the XJ was 50 years in 1968 yes
unfortunately remember 1968 quite well
yes I think this car the XJ was a very
radical car a 96 it this car is just as
radical now as that was then maybe even
more so really yeah I think so you watch
this space I think it will be well thank
you very much thank you very much in
well obviously there's a bit of a buzz
going on on social media about this car
right now it's growing and growing and
iJustine is there maintaining law and
order for us what's going on Justine
there is a lot going on online and
everyone here is also excited but
everyone online is also very very
excited and I have some tweets here this
one specifically from Sergio I have
never been a car guy until they went
electric now the new Jaguar looks like
something out of a movie
so hopefully soon we will see this in
some future movies we have one here from
gadget Jack who says what's your
favourite feature of the new ipace one
of the things that I most love is I've
always wanted to have an electric
vehicle and I think this will be my
first one I love how spacious it is and
it looks amazing - and Doug we've got
here it says it's great to see such a
well-respected car manufacturer getting
serious about evey I agree Doug now the
I paste looks awesome and I love the
tech and especially the in control apps
and I can't wait to get my Spotify
playlist on my driving track of choice
is shape of you by Ed Sheeran hey Jack
no you my driving track
well when me and Ian go on our long
drives in the countryside we tend to
listen to Michael Buble together don't
we nobody okay we don't oh
as you can see Ian is back now with me
in one of his beautifully designed
chairs and we have had lots of questions
coming in we're gonna try and answer as
many as possible fan questions for Ian
Callum I don't know whether that's fans
of cars or specifically Ian Callum fans
that's how much of a big dog he is in
the automotive world he has his own
fandom
they're like Beliebers but mainly men in
their 60s okay
stop it you're feeling me no first
question what is your favorite thing
about the ipace I love the overall shape
of the car it's quite distinctive is
quite different it's quite radical and
of course the fact it is electric guilt
free
guilt free how much has it changed from
the original concept cars what we see
here actually very little a few
millimeters here neighbour overall this
does represent the concept car we built
a concept car that you can buy how
difficult is it building a car around a
battery rather than an engine it's
actually much simpler to be honest with
you because you have much more freedom
you don't have to worry about these
great big lumps of met will be used to
deal with so it's actually a little
easier yeah more fun more fun much more
fun Jags have power and presence like
their designer Ian Callum it doesn't say
that I've added that um these are fine
questions how different is it driving a
battery version without the engine roar
well you know jag has have been known
for the roar of their v8s and strict
sixes but also there's a serenity in
Jagger's history as well the lovely
limousines that were very smooth to
drive this car is full of serenity and
quietness and it's a wonderful place to
be it also has a wonderful interior will
we see a host of new Jaguar cars with
this new modern interior yes this is
actually a template for the next
generation of jakers you'll see lots
more of this and all of our cars a final
question this comes from your biggest
fan he's called Jack and he's from
London and he asks will we be keeping in
touch after this event yes jack
thank you in now yes
Rommel applause please
now one of the biggest concerns for
drivers when purchasing an electric car
is whether or not it will get you to
where you want to go well maybe this
will put your mind at rest
[Music]
my name's Simon Purcell we're out here
in LA with Jacobs ipace our first
electric car this is a TT car talling
tryout car it's one of the first
vehicles after the actual production
facility we have over 200 prototypes
we're gonna take a road all the way to
morrow base so we'll have a good
opportunity to see about this battery
range so we're gonna do this entire trip
without stopping to charge the car will
be capable of delivering more than this
kind of range in real world so let's go
[Music]
how long does the battery in a car like
this last we design a battery life to be
at least 10 years it's nice to not have
to trade up considering the environment
and wanting an electric car but also
being able to benefit from the luxury of
a Jaguar car so and what do you think of
the Ray trip I truly enjoyed this road
trip I think this is a great car it is
absolutely comfortable it's a great ride
and can't wait for it to be on the
market I'm here to witness the moment
where the all-important 90 kilowatt hour
battery pack down there is brought up
and met the chassis of the ipace there
but how does the I pace battery actually
work well earlier today Jack and I
attempted to demonstrate just that for
the help of a large host pipe and a
whole load of buckets
[Music]
okay I'm going to try and explain how an
I paste battery pack works and how you
go about charging it I cannot wait okay
let's start with a basic to charge a
battery you need to supply voltage
greater than the battery itself via some
kind of charger got it the greater the
difference between the battery voltage
and the charge of voltage the quicker
charges
what will charge the battery the other
thing to explain is that in the case of
the I place it has 432 individual
battery cells Oh like the graphs
Carlisle prison interestingly the
third-largest prison in the whole of
Austria the 432 high energy density
lithium ion pouch cells they do kind of
look like cover suits are arranged in
groups and these are called modules okay
imagine a bucket of water what color is
the bucket it doesn't matter it's
important to me okay grey good cuz
that's what I was imagining to charge a
battery
we need to fill these buckets of water
without spilling in estates village is
bad johnny has spillage issues he hates
spinach I split the buckets to represent
three modules okay twelve cells per
module dust 36 bucket our trustee if we
fill them from a hose from to greater
height gravity and also pressure you'll
cause a lot of spinach if your hose is
too high there will be a lot of spinach
yeah Johnny's fixin exactly like this
[Music]
not very efficient lots of spillage but
slow the water pressure down and maybe
reduce the height you can brim the
buckets more efficiently so if you get
your hose closer and you reduce your
flow less village exactly spillage is
inherently inefficient clever thing
about this battery is that the cells are
not charged individua they're all
charged in unison in these buckets it
looks negligible imagine trying to fill
a swimming pool with a hose it wouldn't
really happen but having met my pool boy
becomes very highly rated okay there's
one thing I failed to mention as well
about my pool boy no good because a
decent one is hard to come by these days
at the end there's something important
that happens and this is called cell
balancing this means they're all
constantly being topped up evenly and
this ensures the longevity the battery
pack and also the maximization of charge
and balancing the cells ensures that the
battery doesn't go over 450 volts
yes exactly can I ride one other fire
engines now I'll put your hose away
Johnny thank you Jack and Johnny I think
we all learned a lot here and I'm
hanging out now with jim chapman so this
is pretty exciting so how are you doing
I'm all right I think it's been a long
time since I've seen you yes it's good
to see you again you too I love the way
you say Jaguar okay I don't even want to
talk about it I'm sorry that's how we
say it you've literally never sounded
more American than being right here in
Austria well it's super exciting to be
here now if you do you see yourself
living with an IV or than Evie I mean is
this gonna be the I pace will this be
your electric car that you go to yeah
totally I think that a big thing to me
is my carbon footprint at the moment I
travel a lot for work and I'm trying to
make cutbacks whenever I can so I want
to have solar panels on my roof I want
to start driving electric and I think
this is it's really sexy to look at it
still looks like ejaculate but it has
all the benefits of being electric and
you're gonna be doing a live stream on
Instagram later - correct I am pretty
much as soon as this is over head over
to Jaguar on Instagram because I'm gonna
be taking over and kind of giving sort
of a behind-the-scenes e-type thing I
might chat to you I chat to Jack
chatting to Ian I'm gonna try and out
Jack him if I can
nice so Jaguar or Jaguar what do you
think
I think Jaguar okay I will try my best
throughout the rest of the show right
now we're gonna go find out where Johnny
is because he's been everywhere the show
Johnny where you at I just ain't have a
look at this here we are on the rolling
road this is the bit where the eye pace
is being driven up and having a full
systems check for the very first time
remarkable think that eight hours ago
this vehicle was just a collection of
parts and of course because this car is
electric it's now ready to drive and it
can be driven indoors without any kind
of exhaust emissions I can't wait to get
behind the wheel Jack it's a great time
to be a driver sorry jack
no offence mate I'm gonna stay here and
savor the moment for a bit Jack it's
back to you in the studio
you a medium or a large oh sorry
I was just buying men in some lads on
tour t-shirts to commemorate our dirty
weekend in Graz okay I am now joined by
Jaguars vehicle line director Ian ho
burn welcome another legend in the world
of Jaguar firstly what is a vehicle line
director I worked to get this one right
all no really yes yeah hundreds
thousands of engineers have put their
heart and soul into this car and I
incredibly privileged to lead that team
of engineer amazing that we've got some
questions for you as well first up in
the absence of an engine what makes this
car go though it'll be the two electric
motors one motor on the front axle and
one on the rear in fact you can see the
motors just behind me hanging up how far
does it go on a charge so on a single
charge ipace will go 480 kilometers
that's almost 300 miles it depends a bit
on how you drive but 480 kilometers and
how long does it take to charge at home
so at home it will charge in just over
12 hours from completely empty to
completely full so it will charge
overnight at home and in fact if you're
out and about you can use a DC charger
and you can charge from nought to 80% in
less than 40 minutes I dunno what to do
now cuz my next question is how long
does it charge Alfie about sorry I'm
gonna have to think on my feet and come
up with another question in them
oh dear does it have any cupholders yes
it does have cupholders save miss know
about cupholders and it has four for two
in the front and two in the perceptional
okay that was a silly question
I'll end with a serious technical
question how many rugby players could
you fit in it I'm talking forwards or
backs all very good let's go it backs
backs five easily and a scrum half in
the boot in the boot and it's got two
boots a front boot has the fruit a boot
at the front are we calling it a fruit
or a front
I think we're British so we should call
it a fruit fruit the fruit
Ian say fruit and therefore it is fruit
thank you Ian's now when the jack your
team tests the cars they really test the
cars from extreme weather conditions to
excessive driving the tests a rigorous
and thorough just the way I like my
tests designated to replicate a lifetime
of customer use
it's this car s safe on the road s
normal car the stability control we have
fantastic front to rear bias we're also
able to talk vector across the car so we
can control the talk that we apply
across the car with the brakes as well
aside you feel the the handle light
compares to a conventional car I thought
it would be bigger different like weird
feeling but in this fits really good
ciara good good we have four wheels
right yeah yeah doesn't feel like a
family car they the car felt much
smoother than I thought and yeah it was
a pleasant surprise it was really good
[Music]
[Applause]
Johnny's back how was that for you as a
self-proclaimed car geek yeah it was
actually I mean I loved factories anyway
I'm one of those people I love to see
how things are put together jaguar of
clearly positioned themselves as a tech
leading car company so yeah good times
does it come in blue does it come in
blue it does actually yeah cesium blue
metallic it would it would suit you well
we are nearly at the end of the show so
let's find out how the charge is going
oh yeah
this is the bit where I ask you ask her
yeah Alexa Alexa asked Jaguar remote how
long until my car is fully charged your
car is currently 62% charged it will be
fully charged in 27 minutes is there
anything else I can help you with today
[Music]
there is but not in front of a live
audience
Alexa please can you put me and Ian
Callum down on the guest list for
Paradise gentleman's spa in grass that's
a lot of charge at this level he'll get
you to Prague from Vienna Prague
impressive yeah it only matter of time
before we the charge is finished but
first ladies and gentlemen we're going
to be thrown back over to the wonderful
iJustine thanks Jack now there is just
enough time for a few more last-minute
messages and I have everyone telling me
that I've been mispronouncing Jaguar the
entire time but guys that's how we say
it over there in America we have a
couple more here which everyone seems
very excited and I'm pretty excited bout
the alexa integration we have a question
comment here from Nick Dobson on Twitter
says this launch looks so electrified I
want to be there we wish you were here
too Nick danny is saying Jaguars going
electric this is a dream come true where
do I sign up and Nick loves the modern
feel of this car is this the future yes
it definitely is well thank you guys so
much for tuning in
that's all for me here I had so much fun
in Graz and enjoy the rest of the show
ladies and gentlemen get your wallets
and your credit cards ready the books
are now open you can buy an eye pace so
go and get one and be the envy of all of
your friends Thank You Justine I feel
genuinely enlightened about today we've
witnessed the future and yet here it is
today you can go and own it
pretty cool you taught me about spillage
as well we've learnt so much spillage
thank you so much for joining us here
today in grats for the live global
reveal of the new Jaguar ipace still to
come we have some of the incredible
highlights from the show and the world
premiere of the documentary that you
will not want to miss thank you everyone
for tuning in for more details and to of
course watch this show again which
hopefully you will go head to jaguar
comm thank you and goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
January 2018 a new Jaguar is heading
down the production line
[Music]
but this vehicle is unlike anything the
company has made before
[Music]
this is the eye pace
Jaggi was first ever electric car and
the front-runner in a transport
revolution we've decided to go into this
challenge sooner rather than later
because we are jacket because of
history's urban innovation because we're
not frightened of the new designed from
the ground up the ipace is engineered to
be tough with aerodynamic lines and a
long-range battery powering an
exhilarating drive
[Music]
this is the story of how this radical
new car was made and of how it changes
everything
[Music]
the ipace project began with the highest
ambition to make the world's finest
electric car but achieving this would
push Jagger as designers and engineers
to the limit it's the first big change
in a hundred years in the motor industry
and that's the real challenge for us
designing a brand new car is no easy
task it would take nearly four years
from first sketch to finished vehicle
but going electric and needing no engine
comes with sizable benefits giving the
design team far greater freedom in
shaping the car so remove the people
forward so we'll put the cabin yeah like
so yeah so it's actually heading towards
the front wheels very different but I
think they saw how your work I think
it's gonna work really really nice
proportion so it's all about the drama
of the front hunched and in the rear
horn sweeping Bank this cab forwards
design has given the eye pace ample room
for five large adults none of this would
have been possible with a conventional
engine at the front
powering the ipace is a sophisticated
long-range battery so this is one of our
early prototypes of the battery it's
fairly large it basically fits from the
rear wheels to the front wheels so the
lowest point of this battery is the
lowest point of the vehicle the heart of
this battery is the cell which is not
dissimilar to what you'd find in the
tablets or a mobile phone but we have a
lot more of them
we have 432 in this pack and there's a
lot of infrastructure that facilitates
the control and the cooling and
ultimately the performance of this
battery this new temperature controlled
battery allows the ipace to travel 480
kilometers on a single charge so we've
got to a point where the range of an
electric vehicle is something that
people can relate to their daily laughs
but there's more to this new battery
technology than range alone
[Music]
fast charging points are springing up
worldwide giving the iPass a charge time
from empty to 80% of less than 45
minutes and with artificial intelligence
technology to recognize the driver from
their key fault and calculate the cars
range based on their driving style and
regular journeys the AI pace is at the
forefront of the electric revolution
[Music]
back in the design studio the result of
months of creative effort is gradually
beginning to show and not just on a
computer screen
[Music]
this is technical modeling clay Ian
Astbury job is to cut it to shape it is
great to say common out of just a lump
of clay
[Music]
this has got people's hand prints on the
front prints on it hard work and sweet
the drill bit follows a pre-programmed
route shaping the car was utmost
precision
but from start to finish with rough cuts
and finish cuts we could probably do a
full car in about five days
I feel like it's an important moment
because it's the birth of something
really isn't it
but nothing can replace human skills
when it comes to shaping the clay the
human element is massively important
because without that love and care that
you you know put into a model it
wouldn't be the same you're sculpting a
car you're using clay and you're using
tools to make something come alive
it is a sculpture in a sense with the
clay model nearing completion ian callum
arrives for one of his regular
inspections hey guys all right what's
your about good
ok what do you think but I think I think
is fantastic obviously fantastic the
definition of the cabin and the haunches
it's just right now it's superb he's got
all the power towards the front and yeah
I love it but the stunning shape of the
eye pace is more than just the work of
the designers
[Music]
the engineering team also play a crucial
role and with prototype cars now
available they're preparing for a vital
test one that will influence the shape
of the car and the range of its battery
good test aerodynamics
[Music]
this is a full-scale wind tunnel which
can go up to 260 kilometers an hour and
it's something that is controlled just
by a press of a button so until you come
in here you have no idea exactly the
sheer size of what's behind your test
this really allows us to identify where
key tweaks and changes how they're
impacting the rest of the flow on the
vehicle it's a really really powerful
visual technique for that this is one of
the first prototypes that were actually
built for the real bodywork but we still
have some prototype parts on the car
itself we've done lots of work on plane
models calculations but now this is a
real car truth time
[Music]
it's our first electric vehicle which
means that something like aerodynamics
is even more important we have to try
and optimize it as much as we possibly
can but even millimeters of changes
hugely impacts the range of the vehicle
[Music]
okay
that's looking good in today's test the
team analyzing one of the I paces most
striking features the air bypass it
with no engine the air flows in through
the grille and out through the duct so
what we were able to see with the smoke
is the air being diverted through that
duct and actually creating a much better
angle on to that front windscreen which
hugely impacts the aerodynamics and
ultimately the range of the earth as
well
[Music]
tests like this have resulted in a car
that slices cleanly through the air
greatly increasing the distance it can
travel on a single charge
[Music]
the eye pace is so aerodynamic and it's
electric motors so silent that exterior
noise could easily spoil the cabins
tranquility so engineers are trying to
identify where noise might enter the car
they all have here is an acoustic camera
so for instance for us to click like
this it means to my fingers because of
the high energy level created at my
fingertips
today the team are using the camera to
analyze the dashboard of this prototype
car that there is the perfect view
wherever you've got that yeah cool
that's perfect
I'm out you're good to go
this kind of testing ensures that the
IPS will be as refined as any other
Jaguar ultimately our aim is to create
the most refined battery electric
vehicle on the market today
whether that's road noise motor noise
wind noise anything we need to just get
down to the lower level as possible
but making a near-silent electric car
creates another challenge
like all Jaguars the IPAs is designed to
be fun Ian so fields job is to ensure it
sounds fun too if I just start with the
the first car model that we've got I
will then go in and add some sound at
about somewhere between sort of 50 to
100 kilometers an hour such that it
represents when you are accelerating up
so you get the sense of power of the car
in the electric eye base there's no
engine noise to give dynamic feedback to
the driver so Ian is creating his own it
will play through the car speakers
the next layer of sound I introduced to
to progress is from about 100 kilometers
upwards this is where the sound starts
getting a little bit edgier a little bit
sharper as if that's not enough right at
the very top end above about a hundred
and forty I've got a another sound that
comes in this even edgy is still
so this is us absolutely flooring it
we've got a lovely a trace color hound
there
in the real sense of actually we really
want to pull this car forward and it's
in line with that heritage just you know
we have a history of making great
sounding really fast cars so this one
needs to be no exception
but an exciting sounding car isn't
enough
the team also wanted to be tough
so they brought a prototype to Jaguars
proving ground for a high-impact test
sophisticated sensors fitted by the
engineers will record how the ipace
copes with severe bumps on the road okay
Doug we ready
[Music]
the car cycles through different tests
on different surfaces
but this is only the start
because the information gathered here
is now taken back to the engineering lab
where the car is really put through its
paces
this test will run for the next eight
weeks
the IPS it's a new step for us but we
still test it to the same level as we
would any other product but there's more
to this car than its robustness
[Music]
[Applause]
the ipace is a Jaguar through and
through so the team have come to Italy
to ensure it drives like one
[Music]
this is the Nardo ring a banked circle
of tarmac so large it can be seen from
space it's one of the few places on
earth where cars can be constantly
pushed to the limit
[Music]
today the I place is being tested at
maximum velocity VMAX
[Music]
but regular pitstop safety checks are
essential
[Music]
okay with the midday temperature at 35
degrees okay
okay they saw the team carefully monitor
the heat generated by the cars constant
high speed cornering we have to keep a
close eye on aware and terror that rate
that's some of them can reach up to 650
degrees pit stop complete the car heads
back to the track ready state it's hot
tiring work yet the team are determined
that the eye pace will drive like a true
Jaguar
but Italy was only the beginning in
total the team clocked up over 1.5
million test miles worldwide
even minus 40 in the Arctic on their
mission to make the world's finest
electric car
this is the eye pace
the first all-electric performance SUV
from Jaguar
the future
[Music]